à 48 ans arnaud danjean entame son
troisième mandat consécutif de député
européen natif de saône et loire où il
vit toujours aujourd'hui il n'a plus de
mandat local
il a abandonné son siège de conseiller
régional en 2017 pour se consacrer au
parlement européen candidat malheureux
aux législatives il est cependant celui
qui bousculera arnaud montebourg en 2007
le ténor du ps à l'époque est en
difficulté et ne l'emportent que d'une
poignée pour au cours de son premier
mandat européen arnaud danjean ce sera
président de la sous-commission sécurité
et défense un domaine qu'il connaît bien
pour avoir été avant d'entrer en
politique
agent de la dgse il effectuera pour le
renseignement extérieur de la france de
nombreuses missions en bosnie
herzégovine notamment durant le siège de
sarajevo
il sera également de 2005 à 2007
représentant permanent de la france à
l'onu et conseiller au cabinet du
ministre des affaires étrangères en 2000
arnaud danjean est fait chevalier de
l'ordre national du mérite